now let's go guys to the corrective
waves so as the impulse is the most
iconic pattern of the motif waves the
zigzag labeled abc is the most iconic
pattern of the corrective waves let's go
through the five rules of a zigzag so a
b c three waves two motif waves so now
this is uh a corrective pattern that is
in my example going down so every wave
in this pattern that is going down is
motive so a and c are motive waves and b
is a corrective wave all right because
it's correcting the smooth down
wave a is a motif wave so as we just saw
as you guys now know it needs to have
five waves you know one two three four
five because it's a motive wave wave b
never goes above wave a so this is a
zigzag so the trend must be you know
going lower so of course if b goes here
and you have something like this it's
not going down anymore all right so then
it could be another corrective pattern
but it wouldn't be a zigzag so wave b
never goes above wave a then wave c
usually goes below wave a
so
it's not always like this you can have a
zigzag that is just being
done and stuck in here but usually the c
wave is actually an impulse itself so
wave c is a motive wave so it's usually
an input it can be an end diagonal as
well
but usually c waves in the zigzag are
very strong for example if you look at
the different crises that we had usually
you have the first move down
for example in 207 the move down
happened i think i'm not shouting in
november
then you know it's the market is losing
like 30
and then you have the contrarians you
know the same people that you know just
for no reason they just think oh this is
a good level to buy let's buy it you
know and they all buy it together
and then you have same thing usually the
smart money that knows that you know
this level is now too good and then the
real crisis happens because the
contrarians are gonna sell the smart
money is gonna sell everybody is gonna
sell and usually you have this seawave a
lot of despair and you usually go until
capitulation where basically you know
people are just not going to believe
what is happening the market is just
crashing crashing crashing and it can
last for years guys in
1929 it lasts for more than one year so
when you have one year of strong bear
markets you know the psychological
effects on the investor are devastating
and then you have some psychological
consequences that are just gonna usually
make that people you know retail
investors again the guys that vote here
for example they're usually gonna sell
here you know funny thing and who is
buying as usual guys the institutional
clients the hedge funds you know those
guys that you know know that now it's a
good level and that they can hold the
position if the market is losing 20 or
30 more which retail investor that has
already lost a lot here usually almost
all what they had cannot do so they
usually capitulate at the wrong time but
i can understand i mean you know after
one year of bear market you are not
bullish anymore you know you don't
believe that the market would one day
come back but eventually it always does
so this was the zigzag guys so very
interesting pattern let's go to the flat
first and then i'm going to show you
guys how those two combine together so
this is the zigzag and now we have the
flat all right so what's the difference
so a flat as the name is saying is flat
all right so it's not going lower it's a
corrective pattern
but that usually develops in a
horizontal channel same thing so three
waves a b c wave b always retraces at
least ninety percent of wave a so this
is the golden rule of a flat it's that b
it's almost retracing everything and
sometimes you know it can a bit go above
here or slightly below
the perfect flat is when it goes at the
same level but you know it doesn't often
happen like this usually you are just
closed we are between 19 and 110 so wave
c is a motif wave so same thing this you
know here in my example you know the
time is the same kind of you know but
usually c waves there they can be you
know like this you know it can just last
much longer so there are motive waves
and they can go slightly below same
thing or slightly above guys but what is
very interesting to notice with this
and this is my experience guys i mean i
saw it in the book
but i can tell you that this is what is
happening and i'm going to show you
examples of this we have one more
corrective wave that we haven't seen
which is triangle so zigzag and flat
they usually when you have a zigzag in
the second wave you're gonna have a flat
correction in the force wave guys if the
second wave is a flat then usually the
force wave is going to be a zigzag once
you spot that the second wave
is that you are in an impulse that you
have the third wave you can recognize
the third wave because it's very
impulsive and you can see that here you
have the nice zigzag then you have a
very high probability that this
correction pattern would be a flat so
you can use the flat characteristics
that are here that you know that here is
going to be a motive wave you have so
much information you know that once you
see this you know that you know b and c
are going to be here so you can sell
here by here so triangles this is the
last pattern of corrective waves
triangles are beautiful patterns so you
can have four type of triangles so they
have five waves it's a corrective
pattern so they label a b c d e so a b c
d e and you have four type of triangles
you have contracting first so
contracting is just as we saw for
example with the wedge pattern you have
here a convergence of the support level
and the resistance level and i like to
play this kind of patterns because here
as you can see you have this convergence
so you have a very low volatility at
this levels and low volatility means
that it's easy to for example you put
your buying signal here and your stop
loss just below and usually the market
is behaving quite well in this area so
it's easy to set up some trades and once
you spot abcd you're gonna start buying
here you know you don't buy here all
right you don't buy
after the breakout
if you want to play a breakout you
actually buy below and you stop loss
just here so for example in this
situation
the distance is too large and the
volatility is extreme so it's not easy
to play this kind of reversal moves on
the expanding triangle so expanding
is same thing abcde but as you can see
it's a megaphone pattern this is a bit
what we're having on the s p 500 right
now uh this is coveted crisis i think
we're here guys
i think we're here
so this was ultimate so we are above the
all-time highs we are actually even
doing something like this guys you can
go and check it out we broke this
resistance level and we are now doing
something like this so let's see let's
analyze it like uh step by step when it
arrives but it looks to me that we are
in an expanding triangle and that we
broke on the upside so maybe we are
going to do the fifth wave so you have
ascending or descending there are
basically symmetrical patterns
that have like a horizontal basis so for
the ascending triangle the horizontal
basis is the resistance level that is
here and for the descending triangle you
have the horizontal basis that is the
support level so you have same thing a b
c d e
a b c d e and here exactly as for the
contracting triangle you have this uh
very nice area guys to set up your
trades because the volatility is usually
low for example for descending triangles
for those who have watched my video on
the bitcoin we had a beautiful
descending triangle you know between uh
35 000 and 30 000 you know here i think
40 000
and here like 20 000
and then we saw here the breakout and it
was easy to play and uh you know i used
this pattern to enter some nice trades
on the bitcoin so guys i'm done for uh
the theory so i repeat we have five
patterns so you have the impulse
diagonal zigzag flat and triangle all
right so the impulse is the most iconic
one and triangles are usually guys to
finish on this are usually uh force
weights i rarely see a triangle in the
second wave so once you spot the
triangle it's same thing as when you
spot an ending diagonal you know that
probably you're going to have an ending
diagonal happening so for example in the
bitcoin uh i think we are having maybe
the last wave of the impulse that
started at 10 000 and that is going to
55 or 60 000 let's see because i saw
that we have a nice triangle on the
force wave